answer
same as me and we can see the players
are going into Armageddon and you said
you're a big fan of Magnus Carlson and
of course hikara Nakamura and I'd like
to thank you so much Marcus for coming
into the studio and for your time thank
you
wow and uh Magnus has brought us really
good luck here in the studio because
it's the king's Gambit wow a romantic
opening you nearly never see this in the
21st century and Judith your eyes have
lit up absolutely because this is my
opening when I was a baby I was starting
out with this opening with 2f4
sacrificing the King Pawn there
and I was playing with Bishop C4 not
with this very aggressive from the 18th
century we can say Knight F7 no not yet
oh you want to give up pieces Leo that
black king out into the open but this is
a older variation as you mentioned and
yeah it has a decent reputation a solid
reputation for black I'm surprised
Magnus has given back the pawn No More
Kings Gambit uh it isn't level material
in Hikaru looking away to the left there
that signifies he's trying to remember
something uh he normally has that face
on when he's recording opening Theory
I've had this position myself against
the likes of Nigel short and uh okay
what will Hikaru play I'm surprised he's
gone in for this because Magnus had that
world championship match against Jana
pomonishi in 2021 who had just released
a chess uh chessable course on the
king's Gambit so Magnus will have
studied this in recent times but uh
novelty incoming I mean hikaru's little
poor move never been played before
okay
it looked like the most impressive move
I've got to say Judith no no
chances for white now there's kind of
some transposition and two games in the
database what do you think it looks very
good for black because black is much
more developed right now look at white
pieces it's none of them developed yet
and uh but it's it's really cool that we
have a king's Gambit in in an Armageddon
I played it last time you know in 2010
or something at some point I was playing
a rapid event in Mexico and I played
against Apollo and I won very
convincingly I couldn't believe it
myself it's like a nice exchange
sacrifice or something on that was it or
some kind of sacrifice on F4 in that
game maybe I remember watching it and
thinking wow this is uh I'll just should
be played yeah that was shocking that I
don't even know why I came up with that
idea to play king's Gambit but but here
really white is in trouble from
development point of view right I mean
Knight is going to jump to E5 or D4 in a
second and you can't stop both
yeah you can't stop both once the Knight
arrives on E5 or D4 maybe the bishop
will come out
black will be very quick to Castle
queenside
doesn't look like the king's Gambit has
worked out this time it has backfired
this is unfortunately why it doesn't
make an appearance more often at the top
level
well King's Gambit is something that is
great if you your opponent frightens
from you you know got afraid but Magnus
is not that type of guy he is going to
be smiling at your F4 right
yeah he's normally the one who puts in
all the hard work to surprise the
opponent Magnus and he's got uh given a
position that he probably knows very
well very quickly from him so far but we
have seen two successful games in the
Armageddon where the players have just
played some wild position and they've
sacrificed material and they're saying
you know black simply doesn't have
enough time to handle all those
complications even though let's face it
it probably is a great position for
black because uh the games I'm thinking
of is like Shakura against Ariane he
just gave a pawn has some initiative yes
but that's a different story and
yesterday let's not forget that uh
Escape
trick but uh Magnus pulled on her Wesley
when he sacrificed the whole Rook yeah
but those were already middle game stuff
right and from Mama jarov he just wanted
to go into full complications the
problem is for white here that he just
has no time to develop properly because
you I mean what can you do I mean it's
it's at First Sight it's really
miserable so Knight C3 let's say or okay
he went Queen F2 kind of prophylactical
move black I think will go Knight D5
trying to jump to G4 but another idea is
just to develop with the C8 bishop and
even costs along so the the only problem
for black is that there are so many
tempting options I think G3 is something
that maybe
the plan can be for for white that's why
Magnus played Rook G this Rook G8 is a
different group G8 then after something
yesterday where's the story this one we
can understand Rook on an open file
yesterday a bit more mysterious and okay
Hikaru is threatening to jump into the
center with the white knight this was
cut out by Magnus Carlson uh Bishop B6
really nice move and both sides need to
rush to Castle it feels like uh surely
Bishop D2 is going to happen and White's
King needs to run to safety before it's
too late I want to give credit to Hikaru
they just uh I'm so glad he promised
entertainment maybe this is why in the
interview he was smiling he knew what he
was going to do in the Armageddon he
knew that he had a surprise obviously if
it might have backfired so far but still
early days
yeah maybe I'm not fair that uh that I I
said so many bad things about White's
position maybe it's not as bad as is as
it looked two moves ago
I just don't see how you can be better
that's the problem and you're in a
must-win situation but
but I think your car is just being
practical he's saying you know I don't
care about being better because the
tussles will be happening in the later
stages of the game and if Hikaru is a
bit more familiar with those positions
then you know he can handle them with
great resourcefulness
I like the queen on a F2 actually
because it's it it ties down the C6
Knight and attacks the A7 phone so at
some point Knight D5 can be good or even
Knight B5 the other idea is to go Bishop
E2 and then Rook F1 and attack the F4
Pawn so black should know what he's
doing
and look at magnus's last move trademark
Magnus
gonna go into an end game yeah and uh
not just wanting the Queen's off for
safety but I think it's directly
correlated to Judith's point the White
Queen was actually White's best piece
potentially on F2 and white had some
counter-attacking ideas there so
bullying the White Queen back if it
wasn't a must-win situation maybe Hikaru
would have allowed that trade instead
he's been forced to retreat and suddenly
the white piece is back it's Fisher
random but we know he's uh Fisher
underworld Champion Hikaru loads of the
white pieces now on the back rank what
can black do to up the pressure to
maintain the momentum if white does get
two or three moves he should be okay
watch out for 92 as well hitting the
black queen hitting the pawn on F4 and
okay preemptively again prophylaxis uh
just dropping back with the black queen
maybe getting ready to plant the Knight
on the dominant D4 Square yeah you kind
of feel that White's best move is
actually to put the queen back on F2 but
of course Hikaru is in a must-win
situation cannot do that and the thing
that is concerning about White's
position
how on Earth is he going to develop the
light squared bishop and The Rook
well this is the reason I like the queen
D4 very much what Magnus played in the
previous move because it's not only that
he pushed away the very well placed F2
Queen because it was an attacker but
also it defended the G2 Pawn so right
now Bishop E2 is not exactly possible
because the bone is hanging on G2
okay and a move from Hikaru he does
retreat Knight E2 and that move is given
a question mark by the All-Seeing engine
what could uh why could that be a
mistake
it feels like you can get greedy and
grab one way
I mean hello
[Laughter]
I should rest taking on H2 in that world
championship match for sure he doesn't
go for it Magnus more practical decision
just playing F5 and okay the cross there
means maybe a miss a missed opportunity
for Magnus was that just capturing this
pawn it took courage
instead a safer decision from the former
world champion and G3 Hikaru fighting
back now utilizing this pin the F4 Pawn
cannot be touched you cannot take on G3
or if you can but uh either way you have
to calculate well here yeah and it does
feel that Magnus is losing a little of
the control he had with this especially
with this last move by Hikaru G3 great
move
and we should mention the clock times
three and a half minutes now for Magnus
fauna four minutes uh 50 almost for
Hikaru Nakamura I've seen these two face
off in title Tuesday multiple times
where there's a one second increment
Magnus has lost on time
countless times in their encounters he
always seems to flag against Hikaru so
he's going to get nervous if the clocks
ticked down meanwhile F takes E4 Judith
which one is Hikaru going to recapture I
think G3 was something that Magnus was
not expecting and this is why I also
thought after Knight D2 is little attack
on their fourth one I want to go Bishop
C3 but actually G3 was the idea GF is
very logical
I think black
right yeah it feels strange to allow
this move with Tempo lining up against
the black king on the diagonal hitting
the black queen maybe he's just gonna
drop back maybe he'll just move his
Queen away and say trade-off Bishops
please uh Bishop H3 maybe he'll just
Retreat and there is another question
what about Knight G3 I know and I was
thinking you could back that up with
moves like F5 but okay that requires a
lot of calculation
yeah there's multiple ways to hit this
black queen and Magnus better have some
answers off his sleeve but Hikaru has
slowed down it's really tense it feels
like the critical moments could be
around now exactly I also wanted just to
point out that he spends this few
seconds or maybe even a little more
Knight G3 or Bishop H3 Knight G3 played
on the board The Black Queen has to move
the question is where does she
centralize oh question mark attached to
that move as well maybe a mistake giving
black an opportunity
maybe all I can grab on G3 or what can
be the problem
I'm thinking about going for that A2
Pawn that you've both been mentioning a
few times okay the black queen just
steps back well going for the A2 Pawn
Yeah I wanted to go for it with the
black queen and it's important now that
Queen E4 is not possible because Bishop
D5 would win The Exchange
both players under three minutes well
Hikaru just over and uh we see a trade
of Bishops F5 look at that wow tactics
Galore yeah black cannot take yeah it's
not F5 and Bishop H3
but maybe it's about time to take on A2
no he wants to take with the queen
big threat on the board Queen takes A2
might be devastating and in a
checkmating attack but you can simply
play some safety chests and move the
king to protect that pawn and he does do
that and now Magnus centralizing the
Knight
and again it just feels like any
anyone's game although big threat on the
board of night coming into F3 and so we
we see the same pattern keep repeating
time and time again you know now the
White Queen attacks the pawn on A7 yeah
two can play at that game he attacks the
pawn and Magnus ignores it completely
wow nerves of Steel he's arguing that
Queen takes Pawn is not as dangerous as
it looks because uh later on the black
Bishop will move and vacate a square for
the black king on D7
wow okay it feels like he needs to
gamble it's a bit like magnus's game
yesterday in the Armageddon against
Wesley Queen takes A7 happened there too
and it worked out well for white but
somehow this is not that position
when magnus's Queen was on A7 things
started to become much better than
before and here the The White Square
Bishop will be incredibly strong of
Magnus
and now we can see that the pieces the
pawns are not really good of white there
are a lot of weaknesses yeah Black's
King is safe it's got extra protection
around an extra shelter compared to the
white king and like you say Judith this
is not something that you get away
against Magnus
nothing classical at least but this is
Armageddon
two minutes now for white Hikaru is down
on the clock not good news for uh the
American fans there
what to play It's hard there's tactics
all over the place you're threatening to
take this Pawn undermine the White
Knight on e4 also Knight C4 is a threat
both I mean isn't it time to mobilize
the rook and he does do that and maybe
there are some ideas of Rook takes
Bishop in the air I can see the
evaluation but hating White's position
but still when the players have less
than two and a half minutes on the clock
it's going to get tense
wow and we did see that uh there was a
missed opportunity for Magnus we saw the
Red Cross appear with his last move but
he plays a very safe one can't blame him
for that there are going to be tactical
opportunities later
he's up on time with the great position
as said there in the feature chat Magnus
Carlson right now Kara needs some magic
he's allowed Bishop takes porn
he's done it willingly maybe that was uh
the lesser of the evils there
Smash and grab that what uh that white
porn on A2 has disappeared but white has
gained some time in return going on the
attack now counter-attack
hitting the black queen or Magnus is
zooming In For the Kill Judith
um he's not joking here
no big threat on the board of Queen A5
check and something is going to happen
on A2
something's gonna happen the queen and
Bishop combo there for black looking
really menacing you need to block
somehow with the White Queen with the
white Rooks
but it feels like it's hanging by a
thread under one minute now for Hikaru
maybe he'll play some B4 or something
just to protect this A2 square but it's
kind of hopeless yeah Magnus with a
better position and also more time on
the clock and the players are on move 31
which means that still some moves left
before they get that one second
increment and as we see a set of Rooks
leave the board
yeah Magnus is pulling up and with the
ongoing initiative so that trade seems
to help black in A4 seems to be quite
quite a strong move in H2 and queen H4
so kind of a double attack yeah that
looks like a killer no but uh Magnus
decides to weave a mating net Bishop
comes down to B3 big threat of Queen A4
on the board
almost Unstoppable threat Unstoppable if
you have 30 seconds at least how does
white get his pieces in the White Knight
the white Bishop there just offside
unable to come back to the rescue of
their King
as I said in the future chat there
Hikaru does need a miracle with 30
seconds left queen A4
goes away still some
the fighting spirit is there yes yeah
but Hikaru 23 seconds and uh check uh oh
the white Rook is going to drop the
white Rook is undefended Magnus wins it
but his Knight Falls Hikaru is still
fighting
still in the game for now at least I'm
not even sure that Nakamura did not give
it on purpose with Bishop G4 yeah I
think he had to he had to give something
up but Magnus playing for tricks now
Bishop takes porn really nasty if the
bishop was captured there black had
Queen F4 check picking up one of White's
pieces and now everything's coming
through surely Judith this is going to
be Checkmate if it's not going to be
Checkmate I think he Magnus will be
winning hikaru's Queen at the end of it
on time yep and we see a handshake
Magnus takes the Armageddon Victory with
the black pieces and Nets one and a half
points